[Music]
so george i saw you doing a thing the
other day um
you're like a hacks guy i mean you find
all these shortcuts and these
deals and these ways to do things and
you and rachel were doing some on the
grocery store that were really really
popular and um you were telling me a few
minutes ago
and i thought let's just tell everybody
uh that you're gonna see
number one we are not kidding when we
say in baby step one two and three you
don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
until you're out of debt
because restaurant food is entertainment
it is not nutrition
if you want to spend one-fourth of what
you spend at the restaurant you will
have a better meal when you learn to
cook at home
okay so it's not about it's economics if
you want to do entertainment you do
entertainment when you're not broke and
in debt and don't have an emergency fund
so when you finish baby step three
though
and you're in four five six running
simultaneously yes we go on vacation yes
we go into restaurants and we're not
against restaurants sharon and i will
eat at a restaurant this week i suspect
maybe i don't know sometime but i mean
we we you know we're not every night
people like some of you so but but
so we're not anti-restaurant and one
guy's in the restaurant business you
don't like people in the restaurant i
love the restaurant business i just
don't want people broke people going in
there yes so anyway once you're not
broke people you've got some ideas on
how to save some money some savings
hacks especially on some of these quick
serves yes and now we're not talking
like bottom of the barrel fast food here
because it's hard to beat the taco bell
one dollar menu there's not a lot
there's you can't hack it much yeah
there's a can of alpo beats that exactly
well there's not much real meat in there
some of these fast casual places you
know the paneras the chipotles starbucks
chick-fil-a i put chick-fil-a in another
tier i don't know i agree and panera i
wouldn't agree it's a level it's almost
anything in another tier from taco bell
there you go all right so uh do you want
to do a choose your own adventure are
you a fan of any of those
uh i can't see you frequenting any of
these i'm not i'm not a fr i'm not the
customer and i'm not the focus group so
you just plow right in okay well most of
america maybe steps into a starbucks at
some point apparently they're on every
freaking corner they're everywhere so
i'll give you some some hacks here for
starbucks because
some of y'all are getting eight dollar
drinks at starbucks that don't even have
coffee in them it's just sugar and water
and it's just real fancy and you add
whipped cream on top and you go happy to
give you eight bucks so here's here's
some hacks
okay number one become a rewards member
this is completely free there's no
credit card involved
all you do is you sign up to become a
rewards member and you get free refills
on your brewed coffee uh you get
exclusive offers you get a free drink on
your birthday and you can get any drink
dave you can get a 10 drink on your
birthday if you want to there you go
it's not it's not starbucks it's 10
bucks exactly they're increasing the
prices so that's uh number one
number two get caffeine for cheap if
you're just going to get the caffeine uh
you want that bump you want that
adrenaline rush then avoid all the fancy
drinks and get the brewed coffee and
here's why it has more caffeine than any
of their other drinks a tall a tall
coffee that's the small one dave i know
it's confusing small tall
you don't think of that when you think
of me i'm a size tall in height there
you go i'm just saying that has 235
milligrams of caffeine a venti latte has
150. that's confusing i saw the cartoon
the other day the editorial got the guys
up at the burrito with the barista and
she turns around to the other guy and
goes do we have a flavor called regular
coffee yeah
so there you go it's hard to find these
days so go for the brewed coffee it's
the cheapest thing on the menu and it
has the most caffeine so don't come at
me in the comments there number three
there's a drink that's even smaller than
the tall and get this dave it's called
short
who knew who knew and this is a tiny
drink but you can get the same amount of
espresso in there for a cheaper price or
you get your brewed coffee at a cheaper
price if you really are on a budget and
you want to save some money with all
this inflation stuff going around ask
for a short you can ask for it in a tall
cup that way there's some room at the
top there you might get a little more
bang for your buck
number four split aventi now dave i'm
trying to help you with the sizes here
the venti is the big one okay so if you
and sharon are gonna get the same drink
instead of you both getting a drink and
paying 10 bucks split a venti and then
pour it into an empty cup sounds
romantic so romantic you can drink from
the same straw if you want you can still
do that with both cups i don't know what
you and sharon do these days to keep the
the spark alive
i'm guessing no just keep moving on
george
that's fun and the last one here is go
light on the ice you can ask for light
ice or no water added and you get way
more in there you ever take a drink of
something dave and it's just all i
should it's four pounds of ice in there
yeah and your drink was over in 10
seconds and you go wow that's kind of an
old fast food trick yeah fill the cup up
with i should say that's how i feel
about cocktails too you take four sips
and it's gone you went that was 20 bucks
yeah that's because you're a guzzler
that's right so ask for light ice or no
water added and you will get more bang
for your buck so there's some easy
starbucks hacks and i know a lot of you
give me another one we got we got just a
minute give me another one okay
one more starbucks no no no no another
another company go to uh okay
chick-fil-a everybody loves cheese
chicken right here we go one of my
favorites obviously download the
chick-fil-a one app become a rewards
member all that good stuff but here's
the thing dave i order a kid's meal
because calorically it's still way more
calories than any adult needs how am i
not supposed to say anything
how is it possible i can pass that by do
it here's the deal with the kids meal
you get a drink you get your fries and
you can swap with a toy for an ice cream
dave is breathing so heavily right now
but here's the deal it's five dollars
and you get your food you get your
nuggets whatever you want for about five
bucks another one day it feels like
you're cheating to me you ready for this
you can order a blt at chick-fil-a
yeah but you're a chick-fil-a i know but
dave here's the thing it's a dollar
sixty you get bread
it's a toasted toasted bun with bacon
lettuce tomato so i'm just saying if
you're on a budget you got two bucks to
blow i gotta try that because their food
quality is so good on everything else so
i'll give that a shot yeah and you know
what dollar the sauce is free the sauce
is free pour all the sauce you want on
there it probably don't need to probably
okay 1.60 though because what you're
paying for the sandwich is the chicken
you're paying for the filet so when you
take that out it brings the cost way
down
so there's a lot more dave we could go
all day but i can tell you you're
frustrated already no i'm just i'm i'm
i'm not frustrated i'm just interested
it's um
it's um you know what america wants to
see me and you driving down to
chick-fil-a down the road here and
ordering yeah i think that's our next
video together yeah what do you think
probably not okay it's a good effort i
just wanted to see dave roll up in his
mean old truck ordering a kids meal for
himself
that is the content america needs right
now dave well that would end up on
youtube fraud fraud ramsay's if he's not
a child he just ordered a kid's meal
he's not a child i'll be next to you
yeah as your child that's no i'm that's
it's okay it's all good i'll take a
grandkid and use them as a prop that's
perfect yeah you both kids you got to
get some value out of them so well i'm
just here to save the people a dollar
and here's the thing it's not about so
what's the ones for panera panera
they've got a new value duet piece they
used to have a you pick too now it's
they have a value duet so it's six seven
bucks and you can get you know a soup
and a sandwich oh
that's the duet and you can ask for a
lot of free toppings which is great so
you can double the size of your sandwich
by adding all of these free toppings in
there so we'll pick up a bunch of panera
sometimes on a trip and just put it you
know and they throw stuff in they're
pretty generous
with the add-on stuff all that bread is
cheap they'll throw a bunch well it's
not just the bread i mean they're chips
they're pretty they don't they're not um
they're not
there's a lot of value in general and
the food again they're like chick-fil-a
i think food quality is pretty good for
a fast serve quick serve or whatever you
call them and they have a new sip club
so you get unlimited coffee for an
entire month or you know iced coffee hot
tea for 8.99 so if you go to panera
frequently you're used
on your way to work for nine bucks a
month you can get as much coffee as you
want you can go every two hours if you
want to how does that not
beat all of your starbucks hacks well i
prefer the the quality of the coffee at
starbucks oh
you like the burnt dark roast that's
right well i get the blond rose dave if
you're if you want to get particular
here okay all right
so
there it is so but so panera is not like
dunkin donuts they don't have world
famous coffee see donuts coffee's
supposed to be a big deal too right yeah
i'm from boston and so my bostonians
will say duncan beats everyone but
really they're just pouring cream and
sugar in it and calling it coffee so
sorry what's the difference in that
starbucks well i drink it black dave i'm
one of those hipster types oh okay yeah
okay yeah you like a little sugar in
your coffee america wants to know i'm a
hardcore i mean super strong
like you just stand a stick up here you
want it mine don't want anything in it
no nothing
no nothing as a matter of fact i'll take
a coffee and throw an espresso in it wow
the red eye that's what they call it
yeah okay i didn't know i had a name you
were cool before it was cool i'm not
never never that was never on the list
well it was just it was just a lot of
caffeine involved let me know if you use
the hacks and you save a buck it'll make
me feel good i'll sleep well at night
yeah well thanks for the service george
welder to help this is the ramsey show